whether we like it or not game delays
are becoming super common particularly
for Triple Eight releases and although
it's a generally frustrating trend I
wanted to figure out whether this is
ultimately a good or a bad thing for
gamers so we better start this video off
with why that game you're waiting for
got delayed essentially it's down to the
developer being unable to meet the
timeline set by the publisher when
somebody instead publishing team decided
that so-and-so day of so-and-so month is
the perfect time that they came to come
out a metric ton of planning and
plotting goes into that decision of when
to release a game it encompasses
everything from popular seasonal release
windows to optimal days of the week to
what will help the publisher fulfill
their financial goals in each quarter
and then oh yeah how long the
development of the game is actually
going to take for the guys putting the
hard dev hours in so let's talk why game
delays might be good for gamers and not
an immediately popular opinion but bear
with me Mario and Zelda mastermind
Shigeru Miyamoto once said a delayed
game is eventually good a rushed game is
forever bad delays may be hugely
frustrating but patient game is usually
do end up with a better product most of
the time when we get the news about gain
delays you guys are of the opinion that
you'd rather wait longer for the game
that you expected and not pick up the
cut down or buggy version which is ready
on time there's another solution to this
which we've seen lately with the sims 4
as well as both new consoles and that's
day one updates day one dlc is a pretty
bad look for a publisher when although
the game is out it's in dire need of a
patch since it gives the sense that
whatever you just spent your money on
could be unfinished or unpolished all
right so what about the bad what about
the gamers who feel seriously snubbed by
publishers pushing their anticipated
games back days weeks or months we're
given release dates for a reason because
that's when we expect to be able to get
our hands on
game we might throw some money down on a
pre-order and when it doesn't happen it
impacts everybody quite apart from what
has become the other uselessness of
release dates for gamers given their
rally cap to it's actually publishers
and debs who hurt the most from game
delays let's take watchdogs for instance
that game sat on the hype wagon for a
really long time and not all that was
intentional thanks to a several month
long delay this is the kind of triple-a
release that has dozens of marketing
execs making careful calls on when to
release game info trailers gameplay and
demos all ramping up to the release this
stuff doesn't happen incidentally it's
all plotted out to maintain that
all-important hype train said train came
to an awkward halt when Ubisoft decided
to speak up about how watchdogs would
snag gamers off open world competitor
grand theft auto 5 the company released
an image saying two months are enough to
visit Los Santos come to Chicago on
November 21st then not too long
afterwards the game was pushed back all
the way to the following spring and
that's hardly the only example Jean
Romero's daikatana was delayed all of
three times and it still wasn't very
good and valve totally redefined the
idea of episodic content with their
half-life series and by redefined I mean
they just totally stopped releasing new
episodes after half-life 2 episode 2
this throws everything out for the
game's marketing the carefully plotted
schedule of trailer and gameplay clip
drops and all of a sudden that heavily
advertised release date which publishes
drill into gamers heads for months or
years on end means nothing bad for
publishers rough on busy devs and
frustrating for gamers so let's say as
has been the case a lot lately that a
game just has to be delayed what I'm
proposing is that there's a right and a
wrong way to go about that I talk a lot
about publishers and devs needing to
respect their fans and this is no
different if you're delaying your game
then gamers waiting for its release
deserve an explanation even if you have
nothing more to say than that the game
needs bug fixes and polish this is a
case where saying something bad is
actually better than saying nothing at
all Warner Brothers Mad Max was
announced at
3 in 2013 slated for release in 2014 and
then delayed to 2015 this information
was only conveyed through a trailer with
the altered year and this is hardly the
first time a publisher has opted for
this method of communication
alternatively CD Projekt RED the
development team of the witcher 3 wild
hunt took it upon themselves to release
an official statement to explain to fans
where they were at what they were still
missing in the game where they wanted to
improve and when they expect to be
finished even when no explanation is
offered immediately gamers seem to have
a lot more respect for publishers and
devs who give gamers a real explanation
battlefield hardline and Dragon Age
Inquisition both got hit with delays
this year and although it took a while
EA came out recently to explain why each
game had been pushed back calling dragon
ages delay a matter of polish and bug
fixes and battlefields the opportunity
to include more features and innovation
something even more specific would be
nice but it's better than nothing it
makes a huge difference to include games
in the process even when that process
doesn't necessarily go to plan but let
me know what you think jerking game
delays are a necessary evil or are they
totally unacceptable leave me your
thoughts and I'll see you next week